e aí galera tô aqui no projac
e aí galera que se joga na tudo com você
então então está no lugar certo o
negócio na área banal todo mundo olha só
que eu aceitei guardá lo é a primeira
vitória desde o início também é isso
então na semana santa a semana santa é
que a globo mostra que o nordeste não só
mostra as vacas morrendo mas a escala da
gasolina onde alinha o rapaz de rezar um
autógrafo meu e tudo consegue sair de
casa
[Música]
a nova linha de xampu menstruação de
capivara de sobral para o mundo
era uma mulher perdida
[Música]
é isso aí galera a gente está subindo a
serra da meruoca vai começar a subir a
serra agora ele vai ter que parar para
trocar os pneus do carro vamos rodar um
filme eu de de rali agora que é agora
que vai começar o rali dos sertões
[Música]
andei me veio a falta de você
saudade de você saudade de você
lembrei que eu acordava de manhã só pra
dizer bom dia meu bebê
sean morey 0 harmonia roggia e agora
estão chegando a meu deus ele não é
aquele velho leão tão essa é a vida real
também internética do facebook
até agora sem dúvida eu só não venceu
porque a vida cara não tem mais bala
então equipe honda 18 francisco vem aí
tá aí joão pedro pedro choy de joão vi
dom pedro joão paulo de abreu um
pouquinho machado salvou já o povo negro
[Música]
ae
o making off nós estamos vencendo aqui
um área meio estou voando aqui o povo as
pessoas indígenas um homem pra gente e
galera estou sentindo que fazendas de
hoje estão deixando a essência de por
que eu vi aqui quem vai falar na fazenda
eu querendo vir para um mundo sem
comunicação onde se eu puder ter um
infarto e ninguém ia me achar mundo
totalizaram tirar leite das vacas button
foi o ouro está muito atualizar essas
fazendas que daqui a pouco ninguém vai
me tirar leite de vaca vocês vão fazer o
download do leite b para ficar
registrado eu e é mas é bom galera o
cheiro de o cheiro de terra molhada
a união não cheiro de terra molhada e
cheiro de terra molhada cheia de eventos
é às vezes tem uma poluição outra em
algum lugar mas enfim um pouco com medo
porque é um pouco próximo à nárnia e eu
tenho medo das capivaras 50 me matarem
aqui até das capivaras andré galera pra
você que não sabe isso aqui é uma folha
você tire da internet é galera eu
realmente estou muito feliz meu pulmão
está rejeitando potencial de tanto
respirar de carro e poluição nessa terra
quando este a esse argumento no meu
tempo muito e dá um pouco de falência
mas isso é bom porque vai me restará
meus jogos agora e vocês como é que
assina a semana santa que vocês porque
consegui me falassem os comentários como
está sendo seguido de você aumentar
sendo radical o meio chato porque eu
também tenho a meu bumbum encruzilhada e
paulo fala que bahuan não há
mas o que na vida tudo que sei o quê na
sua vida
a galera é a flor que ofereça a todos
meu fã eu amo você na semana as pedras
galera semana santa a semana santa é
legal porque você não pode fazer muitas
coisas pode comer carne mas pode beber
cachaça não pode matar animais mas pode
beber cachaça não pode falar nada mas
pode ver caixa de francisca fala que o
povo é galera terminaria chega já havia
voado anc que um sol cachorro e
cachorro-quente o carteiro não é galera
pra você que não sabe vou mostrar uma
coisa pra vocês
essa aqui ó terra você que nunca sai de
casa fica nesse computador no facebook
isso aqui é uma folha aqui vocês podem
ver os pés de mangas mas lá dentro tem
pede facebook depois tempere twitter
também olha que bonito gente essa cena
as pessoas caminhando e conversando
entre anos olha que bonito essa cena eu
tenho quanto tempo não vejo isso
[Música]
de um lado existe e da zona da zaga mas
não se acalmar e ao fogo vão deixar
nesse dia o golo te esquecer esquecer
gostei
quem não deixarem pegar a espingarda
[Música]
está te esquecer no entanto é cuidado
quem esquece você cai do cavalo tá se
achando é aproveitar que um dia eu
esqueço na gaveta de um dia esquerdo na
gaveta está convidando é cuidado que
tinha se você cai do cavalo
tá se achando é aproveitar o dia
esquecido na gaveta de anjo que se nós
na verdade
hoje a galera e assim termina o meu
primeiro dia de semana santa tudo muito
santo aqui a gente né é isso aí tá aqui
a galera aqui a raimundinha e jovem
kakuta o irmão de um recado e ea menina
também está aqui também
ele e ele é dia os dois irmãos itaqui
joão neto moreira e aqui também já o
google docs e amanhã vai ter outro dia
de semana santa
muito do santo e é nóis
[Música]
[Aplausos]
arruda conta aí entre uma das 2.368 não
lá fora então me pa
o google do casc digital